well sorry about that guys we
unfortunately lost our internet signal
so we are back up and running now
gremlins are gone everything is all good
the Sun is coming out and there's
wonderful things of foot's shadow and
cover so messing around with a hyena and
trying to find a way to get their food
back but they're not winning at this
stage the shadows just on my right-hand
side have no idea where the Cubs gone
the cub was around the section but
shadows just up on a termite mound it's
the mom that I said I would thought they
might go and sit on is a bit of shade
and now that the sun's come out I think
she's just looking for some way just to
rest and sit down and take it very easy
so nice to see her and you can see she's
still got a bit of difficulty with
walking I point to high spots like this
on top of a mound she's battling a
little bit with the way that she walks
but she's obviously doing just fine in
fact that she's killing fully grown male
impalas means that even though she has
got a slight limp she's more than okay
and I'm surprised she's gonna lie where
she's gonna lie there's a much better
shelf for her off to the right but well
if you're a female lipid you choose
where you want to be and who am I to
know what is more comfortable since I'm
not a leopard but the cub like I said
earlier comes the cub now I can't
didn't know where it was but I can see
it's gonna come up towards mom now it's
kind of striding along there we go hello
everyone I just can't believe how much
more relaxed assist or Cubs Kotzen yet
walk past us just now within a metre do
I know I don't think they look hungry at
all I mean if you look at shadow up on
this mound here you'll see who Bailey is
round and full and it kind of as big as
it's going to be so I don't think
they're in any way hungry it's more a
situation that they want their food back
because it's much easier to try and get
it back than it is to go and hunt
another Impala so it's just kind of such
any patient they know that hyena is
going to eat itself silly and there
might still be some scraps that are left
over then it can go after but they most
certainly are not hungry in it they are
full and they obviously could put a few
little bits into the tummy and and pull
themselves up a little bit more but we
have had a really good meal both bellies
are fairly rounded which means that
they've done just fine you can also see
their rate of breathing is quite fast
which is a good indication where both of
them have actually
it quite well so I think it's a
situation where they're not that hungry
and a beautiful girl she's is just
sitting and relaxing now and if the
cabinet cup has been told you stay down
there there was a little girl just now
how nice is that to have the two of them
up on a mound together and like I said
I'm just been so impressed with this
little one and how its kind of become
over the last few months in terms of how
relaxed it is I watched the sighting
with Noelle the other day when she was
by herself and she was not running or
being shy or secretive in fact they
quite the opposite she was posing and
she was arts in a Barton I'm sure mom
wasn't too far away like Noelle said so
I think that's part of the reason but it
also seems as though she's getting a far
more comfortable with the vehicles which
is wonderful news and hopefully it means
that she's going to continue to provide
us with a lot of sightings and it's
amazing how all of a sudden well not all
of a sudden over the last I would say
three months we've really seen this push
into these areas from shadow and tungee
and we obviously know that Tanya's got
the den site that's now closed and we
couldn't we can't really check there
anymore we will have sightings of Tandy
a lot though around the area and then
her moving around but we have seen a lot
more shadow recently and it's actually
very shadow when she's got a cub that
gets to a stage that this cub is that so
anyway around sort of eight months and
onwards I find shadow actually becomes a
lot easier to find
she's quite tough to find when she's on
her own without Cubs or when the Cubs
are still very small once she's had Cubs
there she becomes a lipid that we tend
to find a lot easier then when she's
without them and it's a strange thing
because normally it's the opposite way
around normally lipids are quite
secretive when they've got Cubs and I
really want you to find them but it's
the opposite with her she seems to be a
lot more out and open and in the sort of
clearings and moving around on roads
when she's got Cubs and that's where I
thought she was going to lie initially
it seems as though I think I might be
right she might decide to lie there
instead but it's amazing how she's sort
of changed oh that is perfect my girl is
that nice it's nice to flop your paws
down him does that not look very leopard
like that's about his leopard like as
you could get but yeah like I was saying
I mean she's become a lot more sort of
sort of noticeable and it was the same
with Cindy Leigh when she had Cindy Lee
she was seen quite a lot amused to see
her you know walking around in areas and
the thing is a lot of people are saying
that she's come back into Juma and she's
spending a lot more time but actually
when Cindy Lee was around she spent a
lot of time in this western part of Juma
she uses hang around maybe not as deep
as what she's going now but she
definitely used to spend a lot of time
in these areas I remember when I came to
some amelie when I first started they
and Cindy Lee was around on the Triple
Aim Road and talking to Brent and
Jamie's tell me that they used to see
Cindy lay all the time and am I in fact
I so used to see some dealer very often
on Triple Aim itself and so it seemed it
was a good place shadow you look about
as queen-like as possible up there and
it's amazing she's kind of got a little
throw now I'm gonna move a little bit
because since is dealing with a stick at
the moment that is in his way so I'm
just gonna try to change full you're
wondering how many litters the shadow
has had well full the answer to that
question is very difficult because
shadow has probably had more litters
than most of the other female leopards
in this area way way way way more than
we even probably know about because
she's lost quite a number of them so
difficult to say I mean I've seen it
probably I've never counted but it's
easily must be seven or eight letters
that I've seen her heaven and so I would
imagine she must have had probably over
1012 I don't know somewhere around there
and in terms of successful letters well
some delays is the only surviving cub
that she's ever had we don't know where
he is anymore we don't know where he's
gone he's typical male and is
distributed out and moved away from
these areas and we haven't seen him but
ya know in number of Cubs there were
litters that she's had difficult to say
she's lost a number of litters before
we've even seen them amounts of times
I've seen a pregnant like I say eight
nine times maybe even more at times than
that I it's it's difficult I can't even
remember the amount of times I've seen
her pregnant it's a high number though
much higher than any of the others if
you think of you know lipids like
gorillas Salish they never had anywhere
near that amount of of Cubs but that's
the way it goes unfortunately she's been
in an area it's just been tough for her
to be able to sort of raise cubs with
with the number of you know male liquids
that we've had in heinessen and various
other things right now taylor mccurdy
who was tardy this afternoon and
talking about the tardiness and what
she's been up to but it seems as though
I believe she's tidy because she's been
making roast potatoes for everybody on a
Sunday and I'm sure she wants to tell
you what about her roast potatoes and
how they've turned out and whether they
are going to be very delicious
for this Sunday roast I'm tardy because
I've been making roast potatoes Kristen
let me tell you a little something I
make the greatest roast potatoes in the
whole world got a sprinkler but
installed but a round black pepper maybe
even a couple of sprigs of rosemary hey
that sound delicious John's not
elevating he's drowning in his saliva
and the thought of my roast potatoes
anyways no we are approaching little
gardeners we were gonna go left we were
gonna hug you tomorrow they go to their
little eastern corner we're not anymore
because I've spotted many cars all in
this area and up against us when tree
nine behind us which you're not going to
be able to see it's all the way up
behind the car even further than mmm
further to the north comes where the Sun
is setting so please excuse me so we're
gonna we gonna hit there and I'm hoping
that we're gonna find either lions maybe
a leopard John says he doesn't care what
it is as long as it's hungry somebody's
in a killing mood and see yeah so we're
gonna head in that direction to a bit
far away oh look it's my favorite scene
in the whole wide world
it's the baboons and I've been saying to
you for so long I want to get the
baboons with the pots and pans today
might be the day look it's so great I
just wish the baboon was sitting a
little bit closer series hello go over
and play with the pots and pans mr.
baboon I think they've been chased many
times and they know better than to go
anywhere near the washing line and
anywhere near the pot rack otherwise I'm
sure is gonna have things thrown at him
or he's gonna be run at by staff members
because I feel like that's what baboons
experience all the time and vervet
monkeys because they're so naughty they
just cannot help themselves they're too
clever for their own good and they know
that if they come around where the
humans are they are bound to find food
if I suppose it just shows how
intelligent they are doesn't it but
anyways keeping a safe distance and bits
double hanging around waiting for an
opportunity
but let's not wait here for too long
let's go to where all the vehicles are
and I think I think it's going to lions
do you remember the evening we had the
really cool sighting of the two
lionesses walking right past the car in
the edge of a lugger and then they
joined up with the young cuts I think
it's that pride I don't she know if it's
maybe gonna be the in Garmin's okay they
all Ola laws or the females that live
closer towards all a lot of gate I'm
actually hoping it would be a leopard
that would be very nice and leopard with
a cub I must seen the leopard cubs well
I think you're going to take this one
yes we're going to take this one and it
seems as though Noel has got the same
idea today she's also searching for the
big cats will he be able to find the
Inca homers welcome Oh welcome back and
hello
so the Inca who knows an iron in an
argument at the moment the one road that
I didn't do this afternoon because I
didn't want to cook that's are too close
to Tony's den site that's where the Inca
Houma is popped up they're not close to
tondee's at the moment so don't worry
about that
it was just the route that we wanted to
take so they popped up there so we're
we're we're having differences of
opinion at the moment but I have another
surprise for you it does involve a big
cat or big cats I should say which might
give it away but I just need you to hold
on for about 30 seconds maybe a minute
and we will see if we can get a good
visual on them
because I'm excited because I believe
it's my first time I'm trying to
remember what what Tristan and I were
discussing the other day about the pride
that we used to see yeah there's a
vehicle on that side and then also on
the other side there John Dre Jean drea
helps me out so much because he sits up
higher than I do he also just has good
Bush eyes helps point out when I have to
find things so we're gonna play I spy
with my little eye something that has
whiskers and a tail do we have any
guesses
shall we play I spy whiskers and a tail
boo you are correct it is lions any
guess Oh which Lions I feel like calling
Lions Leonys today d honestly honest
we're gonna have a vehicle go past us in
a minute sorry sorry all right
any ideas which liens any guesses I'm
gonna keep moving to reposition no
guesses guys come on so it's not thank
Akuma's because they're being mean to me
and don't want to be found
Wendy you're correct it's the Styx pride
yay
all right let's get a better view so we
have quite a few other game drive
vehicles obviously in the area because
for anyone that's been traversing on
this side it's a little bit harder to
find lions when they move out of our
boundaries so it's a bit busy so I'm
just gonna do the best that I can to
position us with the best view that I
can find
oh there's tiny little babies oh my
goodness Andre I'm in love I'm obsessed
and I think I see a male Jean Dre let me
just come up I have a feeling that
there's some males here and I was
feeling it's the cheeky metals that
we're also eluding genre and I the other
day I can just see a bit of the mane
give me two shakes of a lamb's tail
and I'll position ha-ha-ha Camus der
they're so tiny I'm so excited right now
there's their small Cubs but then
there's really small Cubs
Shondra can we go in on the little one
that's in that little erosion patch I
mean everyone come on look at that face
uncle mudar I'm so cute I'm just gonna
turn my body a wee bit little yawn I'm
sorry I am such a girl when it comes to
tiny little lion cubs or tiny little
leopard cubs I am the biggest girl ever
and all I do is make googly voices
and I'm sorry but it's it's too cute so
we have two adult females that I can see
and what looks like one two three four I
would say six to eight month olds to
about ten months old and then those
little Cubs I would put it about three
months three months old that's my
general guess for everything it's a
little bit tricky we've got that big
beautiful male as well thanks Andre one
of them there's another vehicle that's
to our right-hand side that I believe
has the second male from what I could
hear from the guys earlier
I don't know how if you all are excited
but I am ridiculously excited right now
this is very special very very very
special how lazy Chandra I have a
feeling that these sort of six to eight
month old ones are gonna probably be our
most action-packed
at the moment
my Michaels so exciting
I'm so happy to hear that this is your
first time seeing the teeny tiny Bubba's
as well thanks Andre you read my mind
I've counted three mums in a little bit
but thus far I've counted three it's
very interesting with with prides when
they have different litters sorry I'm
also gonna make a correction it's three
different adult females one adult male
and there's three different litters here
two of the litters I'm going to
guesstimate are about two to four months
apart and then the little little litter
the third litter is definitely about
about three months I wouldn't really put
them more it's really interesting when
you get females when you get sisters and
or auntie's or moms that are very
closely connected they'll tend to bring
in their little ones earlier than normal
if you have any in fighting happening
with the adult females in the group
they'll tend to bring the little ones
later and sometimes even separate so
part of the reason has to do with when
you have older Cubs like this with the
younger Cubs the older Cubs are not
always nice the younger Cubs and it can
be quite threatening and also sometimes
the aunties any of the other adult
females in the product are not also
always very nice to the youngsters but
from what I can see look I mean we've
only been here for five minutes but what
I can see thus far is because these
little little ones are with the older
Cubs and all the mums that they have
quite a tight unit and then it works it
works well for them and that's why
they're able to come out I've seen other
prides where females have completely
left and then raised their own cubs and
sometimes have left until the Cubs are
more juvenile slash sub adult age just
over a year before they introduce and
it's interesting how the different
personalities work out like that
I'm sorry how adorable I can hear John
Drake giggling a little bit behind me
too cute way too cute at least without
having seen any mating just by the fact
that the mum of the Cubs is relaxed at
this male I'm gonna say yes sometimes
it's just sometimes when female
territories overlap different male
territories or if there's nomadic males
that come in they'll sometimes mate with
those males but then also present to the
males that are dominant who might not
have been around for the e stressed
that's it's their cubs etc but it's a
touch it's a little touch-and-go I've
seen it happen a couple of times from
what I can tell that this this male is
definitely the father everyone's too
relaxed with with everybody else she's
not in any way looking at him or
guarding or doing anything ooh
teyla has lion but also with elephant
together in the sighting so what we're
not going to go anywhere with our uber
cuteness so while we're sitting here
let's head up that way and see what she
wants to show us the lion is gonna get
charged no I'm just joking it's all very
calm and cool in flakes today as you can
see mr. Mufasa was having to sleep while
this elephant just grazes on the bank of
this drainage line so yeah very nice
very relaxed for the moment I think
there's lions scattered all over the
strange line we've we've already seen
another big male I assume that there are
the triangle boys well at least two of
them and then I see the vehicles are
stopping up ahead of me again so there
must be more lions how exciting I really
am glad that the elephants are here
because they can wake them up because I
don't like to watch the cats sleep for
too long but I think this could be very
exciting and we've got many different
sightings to rotate to as well so it
will keep me occupied which is quite
nice but I don't think this lion is even
acknowledged I hit areas and I can see
him twisting his head just slightly in
turn his ears towards the elephant
he's obviously just keeping an eye open
literally just an ID oh not both of them
and just watching but he's really got
anything to fear at the spot that he's
at at the moment he's up high on top of
a bank that elephant is down low in and
lugga
and even though it doesn't look like it
there must be about a meter in height
difference between where the lion is
laying and the elephant is feeding but
that's quite cool isn't it but there's
more there's many many many many many
elephants around so I'm interested to
see how this all unfolds and what we
might do just now though this one's this
elephant has walked past because I'm
quite keen to see if it comes closer
don't know if the elephant knows of the
Lions here just yet he hasn't really
shown any signs but I would like to go
and have a look and see what the other
cars having a little peek at what a
beautiful afternoon such a variety of
things to look at this is how Safari
should be if only the animals sort of
played ball all the time sometimes they
need a break oh there's another elephant
crashing through the trees up on the
bank and I suspect is going to walk
exactly the same path as this feather
down below and it looks like some
youngsters too so maybe they'll make it
a bit of a noise they might trumpet a
normally trumpet when they get a bit
nervous
this is bubbly cursed are you still
there are you just enjoying this as much
as I am can you can you see actually
just if you got up a little bit there we
go and they'll top left-hand corner if
you watch there there's bushes moving
it's like Jurassic Park what you doing
must be playing with another little
elephant can you hear the bushes as they
crash about
hello meter I haven't heard from you in
ages it's great to hear your voice game
meters my little friend meters only
eight years old
so funny you're wondering if the lines
like to always sleep on the road they
tend to they lay wherever they won't
delay and it's just a pain sometimes if
it's too windy they'll look for things
like trees and shrubs and logs to try
and stop the wind or they'll find a
termite mound but otherwise just
wherever they flop down really like a
like your dog at home or a cat I'm
hoping that little elephant that's
crashing through those trees comes down
this way because that looks like a funny
fella I think he's going to stir trouble
with these lions it looks like he's in
one of those moods there's a whole
breeding herd coming through there and
there's a breeding herd on our right
which we can have a look at a little bit
later then just our knee open at the
moment and they're grazing basically
towards the lugger
so and it seems as though we're gonna
have elephants coming from both ways
soon he's gonna be so close we're not
going to see him anymore
there's a gentle breeze it's not
actually too windy which is nice I'm
quite happy about that because I don't
think many of the animals are fond of
the gusty wind that comes through here
now snazzy you wondering if the lion
knows that he's so close to the
elephants I did see him twitch his head
slightly and his ear went from doing
that to this so I think you know as
elephants even hear him I'm pretty sure
he went from closed eyes to one eye open
and when I'm close to the game went back
to see if he's not bothered at all if he
was bothered he would either sit up he
would change his position his tail would
start to move around it maybe flatten
his ears all these different types of
things okay so that was a great line
impersonation just to be specific that
was as male lion sleeping I could have
done hands I could have done a little
bit more I wouldn't give myself a for
effort there Chris but thank you very
much for the pat on the back but it
wasn't deserving okay let's go out
because I can't see the
anymore and I the lion well he's
sleeping let's quickly look at what's
going on up here
let's see you mean you're gonna have
next we can have another triangle boy
are we going to have some members of the
pride which ever pride this would be yes
baby lions that's what we got
little baby lions also known as cubs I
suppose you call them what they are and
not be said to sitting but there they
sit now this is where it gets
interesting where are the adults because
they're on their own little Cubs are
safe though that's on there on the
lugger so they've got a good spot so
don't worry don't worry these elephants
probably won't squash the coast because
they'd be able to get away they're not
going to be silly enough to stay
underneath an elephant's foot so I
reckon of those elephants that are out
in Europe and come charging towards the
lugger because they pick up on these
other lines there might just run down
the bank and off to the other side very
cool well we're gonna hang around here
and see how this all develops my dear
friend mustard rose potato is sitting
with a beautiful leopard and okay let's
go see what they're up to
well I am sitting with a beautiful
leopard and Cub Taylor Mac and they can
see that they both sleepy now I didn't
think shadow would stay the way she was
for long she was battling to try and
find her sort of position for her head
the wind she was sitting with their paws
dangling like ads and so she's
repositioned and and lay exactly where I
first thought she might lay is because
that looks as though it's a comfiest
spot of all on top of these termite
mounds it's kind of a nice little shelf
little cub has found herself a comfy
spots and it's all distressed now so we
had a bit of activity earlier and then I
think it's going to be a situation where
everything is going to start kind of
getting more excitable around sunset
when maybe more hyenas arrive or you
never know maybe these two decide
they've given up and they'll then carry
on and move off but what an exciting day
we've had so far cat
try Victor once again which is always
wonderful to have little sticks Cubs
it's been I think is the first time
there's little sticks Cubs have ever
been on Jimmy so I'm sure Noel is
buzzing at the thoughts of that which is
quite wonderful and so I haven't even
seen the little sticks Cubs and on top
of all of that there is an income a
female with Cubs some way on Juma at the
moment as well because reax picked up
those tracks and we haven't as yet found
them so I might do a little turn around
there a bit later if we've got no sort
of action happening here a little bit
later I might just head up towards
before look damages to have a little
check you never know maybe one of the
females with the in kuma bride pops out
with Cubs too and that will just make a
ridiculous amount of cats for our
afternoon both in the Mara and the Juba
now the hyena is not feeding at all it's
still sleeping and taking it very easy
now while I wait for our little lipids
to move in fact that one's just crept up
behind me are you sneaking up on me it
seems as though young characters are all
full of play this afternoon so not any
shadows cub but the little sticks pride
Cubs too so let's jump across to Noel
and see what the little ones up to you
alright so we've moved around to a
different position and so there's four
Cubs in total there's three playing with
each other on this log and then that's
that fourth cub that's physically with
them there's not part of the same litter
by the fourth cub I mean that little guy
what could be a little girl I haven't
been able see that's just sort of on
it's ace I would assume that that's the
runt and it's very curious that that one
is not with the other three and as
course as I say that starts moving over
but notice all the bite marks on its
back
oh hello mum yeah definitely the runt
let's see how the others react to her oh
she's going to nurse
special
so it's possible a lot of those scars
come from when this little ones trying
to nurse that that the others sort of
bite and push her out of the way
mom's like it's not time they've got
sharp little teeth little lion cubs so
it's not easy for the mums when they
nurse it's actually quite painful
and it is definitely a little girl you
can look under the tail the one that's
lying on its belly that's a little boy
you can just see the testicle starting
to drop there
so I just want to get my binoculars very
quickly
I also see the size of the paws of the
one on its back very the feet are very
large in comparison to its legs it's
another way to tell it's a male but
those those testes are the best way and
then the one that's on top of him I have
a feeling it's also a male I just got a
quick glimpse and just busy looking with
my behind I was just do triple check
does look like a male so we've got two
males and at least one female and then
we just need the fourth one to stand up
and then we can age that so that type of
information is important to note any of
the ecologist that are on the property
keep track of that yeah
so teyla is up in the mara and also has
some babies that are playing around like
our little lion cubs so we're gonna send
you back up there so you can have a view
and we will sit tight here and see you
just now being so precious a little
while ago I'm hoping they're going to
carry on playing but the three elephants
that you can see in other little ones
there we go those three were pushing and
shoving one another down hills
I heard the strange trumpeting noise and
they'd both jumped on the little one
and it was desperately trying to get up
again and it's just so precious it was
absolutely adorable and there's nothing
cuter when young animals play it
actually doesn't matter what species of
animal is it's always so incredible and
then there's a tiny tiny tiny little
elephant that is not even interested in
playing with the others just yet it is
only wanting to follow Mom around and
it's been trying to suckle but mom won't
stand still so you'll see every time mom
stops
Grenn's up to underneath her arm and
warm underneath her arm underneath her
leg and tries to have a little suckle
it's not quite quick enough just yet
it's still still trying to work out hard
as suckle efficiently but it is precious
mom's just on the move she's hungry
she's not interested in anything else oh
there we go come on there's your
opportunity see it takes too long now
Richard you're wondering if elephants
give birth standing up they most
certainly do
quite a few of the animal they sort of
do the what's this little elephant is
doing right now but it's not giving
birth but it's it's about a similar sort
of action it's demonstrating very well
for her since afternoon thank you little
elephant so they do so often when
animals hit the ground I mean a little
elephant actually doesn't have to fall
far I feel sorry for a giraffe I mean
that's a that's a long way up and a far
way to fall and and often just
encourages animal to take their first
breath I suppose it kick-starts the
ranks doesn't it but it is very very
tiny but you saw what I mean there and
it's not quite quick enough working out
that you must go
right to mom's breasts when she want
when you want to suckle because she's
gonna just keep going she's gonna stop
she's obviously got her mind made up as
to where she wants to go and she's gonna
be there by a certain time
I'm just waiting for some of these
vehicles to move off so we can have some
fun with these lions it's just getting a
little bit busy at the moment
but everyone's gonna have to head off
soon so then we'll have this whole
sighting to ourself but we'll let all
the guests experience it and have some
fun have traveled a very very far way to
be yeah although survived but I'm lucky
I kind of live here don't I well at
least for the next until February which
is pretty cool just spending so much
time in my er and we haven't had any
rain and it doesn't look like there's
any rain on its way just yet either so I
suppose that's a highlight for today
it's been very nice or this morning it
was spitting at one point but then
luckily the wind came on in and blew the
clouds away very cool what else is going
on there were some crowned cranes
hanging around too but they seem to have
moved off but now I heard of elephants
is also moving in the opposite direction
that we wanted them to move if we wanted
them to chase the Lions they are now
going east where the Sun rises the Lions
are back that way all right I think it's
time to reposition and go and see what
those lions are drink Scott is copying
us this afternoon he can't be original
he's also found some elephants
and we are spending some time with them
in the hope that he decides to walk
along the horizon where we will be able
to get some incredible silhouetted shots
of him there's a very moody sky as you
can see in the background and he is a
fine fine specimen indeed as you would
have gathered we left the musketeer
coalition they had not left the carcass
by the time we left them but we thought
it would make sense to come and look for
a female cheetah that we had a visual of
this morning not too far from where we
are now but we couldn't pass this
opportunity up
as it really is a beautiful beautiful
scene come a dark star you'd like to
know if elephants tusks serve a purpose
and yes they certainly do both male and
female tusks will the elephants will use
their tusks it looks like he is going to
kind of possibly see me silhouette
himself not perfectly but just about how
beautiful is this and what a wonderful
wonderful scene so yes they will use
their tusks mainly as tools for feeding
snapping off branches of trees prying
bark off trees and from time to time
males will use them when they are
fighting with one another and I guess if
they get a hold of us as humans they
sometimes also use them on us so they
use them as weapons but usually they
don't get into many fights with any
other species
the main fights will be between bull
elephants over females and the size of
the tusks how much of an impact that has
on any bulls dominance I'm not too sure
some tusks that are too big let me try
to reposition one more time some tusks
it are too big may actually coming a bit
of a burden to carry around
I'm hoping to try and still more low
angles on him there's a chance we could
get him silhouetted
fairly substantial loop ahead to give
ourselves enough time know enough gonna
be able to get low enough but we'll
still get some beautiful views of them
walking towards us with a wonderful
backdrop wonderful
lasting is there we can't get the exact
shot we were hoping for I think we may
head on in the hope that we find this
female cheetah that we with this morning
oh we need a rush you off to some cute
cub cuteness cuteness and they are cute
indeed oh my goodness they're providing
us with ample amount of laughter and
giggles so from what I can tell it's
looking like three male Cubs and two
females which is very interesting so the
male that was in the background that we
showed earlier Shaun Dre and I were
chatting now is Andres pretty convinced
it's one of the Birmingham boys which
would make sense and as far as I know
they're a coalition of three so now this
group of youngsters of the four three or
boys and will most likely form a
coalition themselves but what is also an
interesting thought to think about is
we've got these young young cubs
and then we've got the two sets of older
Cubs also different ages so it's
entirely possible that the males the
majority males out of all of them will
form some sort of super coalition and
the sabi sands is known for having very
large coalition's of males that traverse
we talked about them of pole holes the
other day that coalition of about six or
seven males that's sort of rampage
through the area I'm hundrets giggling
behind me and yes it's super super cute
so other than the cuteness factor the if
all of these males survive and I have
yet to see the older ones move enough
for me to be able to to ascertain how
many males and how many females the
concept that we could have a future
super coalition of males within this
area is absolutely fantastic in my head
seandrade you see the one that has a bit
of bond so one of them has a bit of bark
oh it's just dropped and he was carrying
it around sibling tried to come and take
it away I'm just gonna be quiet for a
minute and just let you all enjoy
there's there's thorns on these stick
city me sticks that are here on the edge
of the dam our brush pack our brush
packing the the side of the dam wall so
that no one drives up and down them and
also to help rehabilitate there's
there's quite a bit of erosion that's
going on and a lot of the sticks that
are being used are from nob thorns
I'm serious thorns on there so you got a
little bit of tact and decided chew on
it and then you so much just there I got
stuck in his little lip
or her little lip rather that's a little
little rent one
Michael your question is our baby lions
born with teeth Michael as far as I know
they're not born with teeth but they
developed shortly after birth as far as
I know it's hyena Cubs that are born
with teeth I'm pretty sure I'm correct
on that one sorry I'm rocky my file 13
in my brain at the moment it's a good
question I love the questions you all
ask because a lot of them are it's not
something that I have been able or
hasn't been asked with my guests in a
really long time so it forces me to go
back through my files and and relearn a
lot of the information that I used to
know before it's keeping me on my toes I
like it you must keep it up
I didn't do it you're asking why do
these Cubs have a black line down their
back and that's little tuft of hair that
goes down the back the the adults will
also keep and it won't be as dark as
they get older but we were chatting a
bit about it yesterday afternoon when we
were with the Inca Houmas about the fact
that when they're hunting especially
when the females and with the males as
well because the male's hunt just as
much as the females when they're
staggering themselves especially in
grasslands it allows them to be able to
see each other it's sort of a dark line
but that being said it's not the only
reason it also has to do with breaking
up the the body shape and the coloration
and allowing for a bit of camouflage in
there
so even though it was warmer this
afternoon we're getting closer to to
sunset so we're starting to get some
cicadas and crickets going Sandpiper
flying above us just now earlier in the
drive Jean DraI spotted another
woodlands Kingfisher and that was
calling but unfortunately it flew off
before we could get it on the live
camera for everybody it is also
interesting that these cuts are playing
but they're not making any noises
usually here and they grunt a bit but
they're being quite silent which is
interesting shame that one's attacking
its older cousin let's see how this goes
[Laughter]
it's not really working so now that a
little bit of grooming that's the I
wanted to be like play with me play with
me then the older cousin didn't do
anything so now it's going I love you I
love you
i tol you're asking to these Cubs look a
little too skinny to me the answer is
definitely definitely not I have a
friend that has son who is extremely
active so he's always been quite thin
he lost his baby fat very very early
because he's constantly moving
constantly moving
he also prefers to eat a lot of protein
he doesn't eat a lot of anything else
and so he's doesn't have fact on him so
with something like cub it's gonna be
the same thing as a young child that has
that where they get these fat little
bellies when they eat but that you mean
you can see everyone else is sleeping
and they're very active so they're
constantly burning off so they've got a
little bit of a milk belly on them at
the moment you can see there and then
because they're learning how to use
their limbs and their metabolism is
gonna be quite quick because they're
little they're perfectly happy perfectly
happy yes for one but also very very
healthy if they were too fat so fatter
than this they wouldn't be able to
function as properly and also would
throw off their body chemistry there
they're good they're very good
sorry curse can you just repeat wills
question for me please
Oh a - won't curse is a sausage dog yeah
okay so will you're asking how bigger
these Cubs - moon size sausage dog size
or house cat size
thank you for asking that question
something I'm still getting used to is
you guys not being here I know you can
see it but then obviously the size so
for me I would say closer to sausage dog
- and then a house cat I would also put
them in the range of sort of a eight
week old labrador puppy size if that
also helps anybody I've got a virtual
schuylkill in the background I'm
obsessed with this idea everybody and
John Dre is giggling behind me he's also
a bit obsessed with this idea I think
Miss Parker you're asking will the Cubs
go back to a den site or will they stay
with a pride now shaundra that one
little female is busy nursing on the mum
I think we might be able to get a good
shot if we move to the right they're
fabulous thank you so much look once
with lions once they take them out of
the den and bring them to the pride
that's it and then they're out dens are
used usually for no longer than three
months sometimes a lot shorter the
shortest I've ever seen me personally
and every guy could have a different
experience here shortest I've seen is um
two months with a den so a den site is
only used for giving birth and they'll
switch they they usually switch one to
two sometimes up to three times
depending on how many how much
interaction they have from other
predators or the sort of smells and
everything that's going on or or
anything that could possibly have
interfered in any way and also just to
sort of mix it up and move it closer
they'll usually give birth in their den
site either where they were birthed or
sort of in their core territory and if
their arrest their pride has moved to
the outside peripheries of a territory
or into the home range then the mum will
start to move ten sites closer to that
side so a Dennis used for a very short
amount of time because these especially
with lions there are social animals and
they need each other to to hunt and to
survive good question
so you'll notice now I mean we've been
here for a half an hour I would say
roughly and they've played quite a bit
but one female did try to nurse but mum
wasn't ready now it's feeding time now
they're all gonna go in a nurse and
they'll nurse for quite a while five to
about 20 minutes depending and then
they'll have fat little bellies and they
might take a little nap or some times
which you'll see because as they're
finished with the nursing then the
prides gonna start to get moving none of
them look overly full I don't think that
they've had a kill super recently and
then the mums just giving sustenance for
for the trek for tonight another reason
is that her teats start to hang low when
they get too full so it's very
uncomfortable for her to walk around
with teats like that which is why the
mums when when the Cubs are in the den
site the mums try not to leave them for
more than about four days or so it's
because it gets uncomfortable for her
another thing I want to point out
regarding the question we had about the
about the downside is with these little
little Cubs and actually with with all
of the the Cubs that are in this pride
now none of them are really old enough
to help with the hunting so what will
happen is when this male and these three
females start to go hunting if they come
across say let's say I've build a beast
just for argument's sake the little ones
will will be told to stay put where they
are and they'll duck down and then the
adults will do the hunting once they
make the kill the little ones will join
that male lion is out for the count
I think he's opened his eye once and set
up once
sooo you're asking why do the Cubs have
spots on their legs so what you can see
with the older Cubs and then also these
younger Cubs that are coming through
they're born spotted I've even come
across a lion cubs that haven't almost
rosette background to them the females
will keep those spots especially on
their legs you can actually see a little
bit on the mums leg just at the top of
the screen there throughout their lives
the male's will lose them totally and
it's all for camouflage it's all for
blending in
some things that I wanted to address we
were asked earlier with who's the dad of
this pry of these youngsters and they
visit this male because this is one of
the Birmingham boys he's in a coalition
with two other males so all of the males
will mate with the females at one point
usually when one female is in Easter's
when she's ready to mate there will be
one male that services her out of the
three but the three of them take care of
the Cubs as if they're their own and
protect as this they're their own so
this one could possibly be physically
the genetic dad but it could be the
other two as well and there's there's
not really that much much difference
amongst it all right we are going to
head off didn't quite hear what Kerr
said where we're going so let's keep it
a surprise for everybody who knows maybe
we're going to Tristan maybe we're going
to tail it maybe we're going to Scott
you never know
see what happens how to have just woken
up they were sleeping ever so gently on
top of the termite man and all of a
sudden shadow got up she hissed at me
and then she decided to walk off I she
seems to be quite grumpy with the cab
the cab following is following her
everywhere and I think she's had enough
of the cub and the hyenas and the
nonsense of her kill being stylish and
she's a little on the grumpy side at the
moment but that's okay she's expected to
be a bit grumpy I would also be grumpy
if hyenas came and stole my kill as well
now she's going again back to the exact
same place this is originally where the
kill was some way in this general area
and you see how she's sniffing around
and having a little look for some sort
of sign of food so she's looking and
here comes Cub as well so it cubs also
coming past us it's like a procession
when Mom walks and then cub follows
shortly after they made myself out of
the way sorry since then we go cub goes
and you see how the cub just keeps
sniffing exactly where mommy is I think
this Cubs hoping that mom managed to
save something of this carcass and that
she can follow Mom to some more food
although I think shadow is far as kind
of realizing that most of her killers
we heard that unit crunching some bones
just now and having a little feed but
didn't last very long I think that Hein
is so full itself when it was dragging
the carcass away it was like a round
beach ball that it shoved a whole bunch
of meat into its mouth and I was looking
really quite large and so nothing that I
earn is just going to literally lie on
it and I'm sure it's crunching will
attract other you know there's lots of
vultures sitting here now so I would
imagine we're gonna get a situation
where they will attract more what have
you got there looks like a stomach
lining maybe that she covered up or
there's all the internal organs you see
how I covered those races she dragged
stuff all over it look at that that's
amazing so she managed to cover up all
the innards you see there she's pulled
out what it looks like the stomach and
so she might eat the lining of all of
that and be able to get some nutrients
from that whether the cub will get a
look-in I don't think so
she generally tends to be quite nasty to
the cub let's see if she's gonna grassy
the cub is just sneaky and you see the
little face coming in no everything's
okay yeah there we go
you hear that sorry little one no food
for you right now mommy's hungry
Shane got told off
you're not coming anywhere near my
little meats and the thing is is that I
don't think shadow will finish all of
that stomach lining so maybe the cub
will be able to get a chance to get in
there now Suzie I know you asked about
whether or not if shadow lost the kill
would I think it was would the cub go
and regain it again I think that's what
the question was I might be herded wrong
and there we go so sorry I heard it's a
bit wrong Suzie you say I'll shadow
doesn't hoist her kills with the cub
ever hoist well I think so I mean Shadow
has wasted one or two kills that we've
seen we've also seen a situation where
the cub has that sort of notion of going
up into the tree remember the last time
the last two times we've seen shadow on
a kill both times the carcass has
actually invention ended up in the tree
and the little cub has been there so I
know shadow doesn't waste as much as
what we would hope but she definitely
does and look at how this cub is trying
to sneak its way in little one you're
going to get a smack from mom now now
yes be careful you can't go in it see
she's trying a very best look at that no
it's not going to work mommy's going to
smack you on the head now now and you'll
find that leopards are like this they
very seldom will share they're not like
lions in that lions will kind of feed on
a carcass together and both will be
there lipids will be a little bit more
sort of defensive and we'll only eat one
at a time and this poor cub is trying
its best it's even sometimes making
little chuffing sounds which is the
sound that mom normally makes when it's
looking to call it and it's trying to
kind of get its way in in be as
submissive as possible you see how it's
gone low to the ground just trying to
make sure that mom kind of leaves it
alone and actually feel sorry for it
more than anything else but sorry little
one I don't think you're gonna get any
of that I'm afraid
who knows maybe maybe she'll get lucky
and shadow will leave it the nice thing
is there's a little bit of afternoon Sun
that's broken out and it really is
looking absolutely beautiful as it kind
of just goes on to these leopards Shh
come on little one it's amazing to watch
honestly I've never seen a female
leopard as aggressive as shadow has been
over the last few weeks with the cub and
food and tools you know normally when
it's that time when they chase the cubs
away they get to be a little bit kind of
nasty but Shadow is always scowling at
this little one and sort of making it
feel as though it's not welcome and
there we go I think it might have gotten
it aside for itself let's see are we
gonna see a situation where both of them
feed off the same thing I don't think so
I think you see now she's rolling so
she's trying to show Mom come on mom I'm
hungry let me have some of this please
so she's doing all the techniques to try
and make mom feel sorry for herself it's
basically like a little child when it
wants something from a supermarket or a
shop whereas and it's it just goes on
and on and on and asked and asked and
we'll try every angle it's the exact
same thing with this cub but you can see
what shadow's doing is she's basically
stripping the lining from all of that
rumen so all of that grass that was
inside of this Impala stomach she's
stripping that all orphaned and she's
slowly but surely swallowing chunks of
that skin and that stomach lining and
out it is going to be full of nutrients
so it's not a bad thing for her to eat
this is probably not the most tasty part
of the carcass it's why she probably
pulled it out and buried it but
if you've lost the carcass you might as
well feed off it and get the nutrients I
can tell you though that the smell is
quite pungent from here there's a strong
rumen smell it's amazing when you first
smell that it's quite foreign but once
you've smelted a few times it's
something that look at that light on it
how beautiful is that so it's a small
that you'll never forget it's kind of
got this very I don't know what the word
is for it but it's it is a grass you
smell but it is a lot more pungent than
that and you pick it up straight away
whenever you kind of come across the
stomach that has got rumen that's lying
outside of it you get that but it's your
little cub is just moving off now maybe
it's gonna find something of its own
hidden here you never know she might
have hidden other organs no I'm gonna
have to lie down sorry little one you
don't have to wait for Mom
unfortunately right now as the Sun comes
out here at Juma for the first time in
the last few days I believe Scotty D is
sitting in the Mara has a beautiful
beautiful view of the Sun actually
disappearing over the grassy plains of
East Africa well is this not a
absolutely breathtaking scene a gorgeous
gorgeous sunset here in the Maasai Mara
with a Quinta net essential pala
nighties tree silhouetted on the horizon
and a whole array of beautiful beautiful
clouds and some Thompson's gazelle in
the foreground absolutely magical it
sounds like you're having a great
sighting with a Tristan and what a day
it's been filled with big cats and lots
of action who knows maybe in Tristan's
leopard will also get lucky on a hunt
this evening absolutely magic
we we saw the prospects of this
beautiful sunset and we're racing around
trying to find some animals at a low
enough angle to be able to get the shots
we wanted and the beauty that you're
seeing here not quite perfectly
silhouetted but it was good fun trying
to find the right subjects to show you
guys and just in the nick of time we did
and the lights changing rapidly Simona
was having to think on his feature and
adjust the settings as the sizing
unfolds he doing a great job Manu
surprisingly only kidding
well what our dad's been mono and I are
looking forward to a cold beverage of
sorts after a long day arts and while we
head towards an outlet that will provide
us with a cold beverage we are going to
be sending you across to Taylor who is
also enjoying a beautiful sunsets did
you just say you're heading for a cold
beverage or did I make that up did I
want to hear that this Scotty immune man
you make me laugh but how incredible is
the site that we've got and listen to
the sounds as well
No we might have got you just at the
right time although you might have got
you at the right time we've been sitting
for for a little while but it's been
absolutely amazing I mean big male lion
was a big full belly covered in flies
that's a bird chirping and then of
course the Setting Sun and all its
beautiful colors that it is brought to
the sky this evening I think it doesn't
get much better than that in Africa
that's all I can say especially with the
way the trees are lined up that will
most certainly make a great screensaver
Wow Wow if only I could take a picture
that could do it justice I don't think
so I don't even think how you see things
on camera sometimes portray how
beautiful they really are this is
incredible all right
that's very nice let's go around and see
what our other lions up to we have to go
I'm just making trouble driving to
anybody I seem to have a tendency to do
that
right it's good ah sleepy max leaping
Jenna's got his head up now so we all go
and have a look at him and hopefully
once you've seen him we can go back and
that other fella would have also working
out I'm just checking I thought
something was wrong with a camera
everything good okay
sometimes the cameras just tend to fall
off with all the corrugations that we
have to go over I'm going to make sure
that we weren't going to lose it
we'll stop in there little minute we're
almost there
and he's just gazing off into the
distance it's very pretty
we might stop by to bow
yeah I just want to give you with that
other car just to show you where the
Cubs are and also just to show you how
the male's don't really care that the
covers are over there he's got no
interest whatsoever so not too far away
if those little ones started whining
he'd hear them quite easily and I don't
know if he'd go running to their rescue
from a herd of elephants came charging
through not sure about that but that's
one of the Rangers so they're allowed to
stay out as necessary like I think
they're also part of the and poaching
patrol that isn't this a beautiful boy
who are you under the triangle boys all
the Keturah males is it also known as
we've got dental record there was your
opportunity to check and got to be quick
though lovely dark mane though there are
very pretty boys they're not
particularly ugly lions what have you
heard you listening she will friends the
elephants that are still in the forest I
think that's what he's doing at the
moment and that's why he turned his head
so quickly and we have a little listen
and see if I can hear anything
I can hear the leaves moving from the
wind I don't know what he's heard but
his hearing is also way better than mine
so whenever he's listening to well I'm
not sure then we can hear the cuts
he's intrigued by something very fixated
down the lugger he's a bit of water in
that lager I wonder if maybe a little
Angelo but something hasn't come down to
have a drink and that's what he maybe
he's seen something maybe he hasn't even
heard anything and my eyesight is gonna
start to deteriorate and hisses I only
get going to get even better I mean they
can see six times better than what we
can at night can you imagine being able
to see six times the strength your eyes
can see at night incredible it would be
really wonderful I bet I'd be spotting
all sorts of rodents doing all sorts of
things and they just sits and not
another big yawn
I think he's youand out okay I'm gonna
bounce up and down I might go and have a
just a little check on the Cubs see how
they're doing and I suppose Noelle's
doing a little bit of babysitting
herself it seems as though she is
watching the young sticks cuts here is
your screenshot of the day with this
uber cuteness
so full from having just nourished and
busy resting his head and then the
sibling that's behind him sort of
cuddled up and I was a little paw on his
back he's just pushed him home Oh shame
absolutely adorable so um the mom got up
and moved off a little bit and then one
of the other adult females is also
moving around a little bit they're busy
grooming each other so they're
definitely gonna start moving soon I'm
hoping when they move they go down for a
drink that will be lovely we're actually
gonna have a sunset tonight as opposed
to some clouds there's a fish eagle
calling in the background I don't know
actually it's not a fish eagle sorry I
think it's a Wahlberg so I'm losing my
mind a little bit um I don't know if you
all could hear that there's the spots we
talked about earlier
that's a nice screen shot as well that's
super cute
Tristan also has some uber cuteness I'll
be an older uber cuteness we're gonna
head over to him and give you all a
chance to see shadows youngster I do
have cuteness I have a cuteness overload
shadows little covers just talked all
the way along over the top of the mound
to try and chase its mom and to try and
jump on her and she went flying off the
top of the mound and now they're having
a little game look look at that how cute
is that isn't that not the sweetest
thing a little bit of bonding a bit of
grooming so even after but kissing and
kind of going at each other and having a
little mom daughter feud they at least
have managed to figure their things out
and have at least got a situation where
everybody still loves one another and
they're still going to groom each other
very cool to see I love it when little
baby or leopard Cubs get playful it's
the best thing in the world and you
might find she do do it again and it's
all important for later in life it helps
her practice helps her get used to
what's going on and to be able to learn
how to hunt and hunt down things like
male impalas all by yourself later in
life so it really is a wonderful thing
to watch and we had such a beautiful
sighting of a bouncing off the mound
itself now since I'm just going to move
you slightly forward because at the
moment what's happening is my shadow is
actually in the way of there we go how's
that that's beautiful light now now the
little Cubs is still moving around quite
a bit and you're still coming this way
but look at that light on shadow it's
just that perfect afternoon post kind of
cloud you stormy weather and you get
this orange rich light that gets onto a
lipid and lipid can not look any better
then when it is in warm light like that
so you can see a couple of the vultures
in the background and here comes the cub
again and I just watch the cub if the
cub gets close she'll start to kind of
stalk down and she gets a little bit
lower and she's slowly but surely then
starts to kind of stalk on to mom and
maybe she's not gonna do it now although
it's I think cuz mom is spotted oh but
look you see she's going down and she's
just rolling and you'll see once mom
loses sort of patience and stops
watching her then she starts her stalk
again so she's really got that kind of
motion down pat so she knows already
hard to be able to stalk without being
seen so as soon as she
gets watched she stops which is exactly
how leopard will be is if an Impala
turns towards where she is if they'll
stop and in it you know they'll then
carry on once the Empire looks away and
it's the same with mom so she's learning
valuable techniques by a stalking mom
and to try and hunt her mother is
actually a really really good thing for
her so amazing to watch and like I say
it's it's interesting to watch this
little cub as it goes about its business
it doesn't sit still for two seconds the
whole time we've been here yet he's been
moving around there any time we saw it
actually sleep was when mom was on the
termite mound and there really wasn't
much going on early in the afternoon but
other than that it has been moving all
over the place and that's what's making
its mom move now it's just seen a
vulture fly away so I think it's got a
situation where it wants to go and
investigate but the vultures are very
far from where we are now they're right
on the distance in their eyes and there
you can see all in the big tree over
there so that's where you can see the
branch it's actually wobbling that's
where the vulture flew off from and
landed on the other side so it went
quite a long way away in it but that's
not going to stop it she seems as though
she's going to go one door and
investigate what are these large birds
that are congregating in this area maybe
it's also a tactic to be able to get
some distance between mom and herself
that she can then start to come back and
stalk this way no she's heading way off
towards the vultures you can see the
little white tip to the tail heading in
that direction I'm sure she's going to
lose bravery fairly shortly and she'll
turn around they'll happen it's gonna
just stop and watch them there or there
I think she's actually looking up at the
vulture that's not far from it is one
that's just up to her left-hand side and
I think that's the one that she's rather
going to be watching than the ones far
away and she's quite curious about this
big bird that is sitting at the top of a
tree and watching her and it's almost to
stay down between the two at the moment
very cool little cub you're going to
learn to hate vultures vultures going to
attract a lot of danger for you and a
lot of things that steal all your food
okay let's see now she's gonna stalk
know mom is watching her side I don't
think she's got any chance but what she
was doing earlier is quite clever she
was learning to use cover and so she
went around the mound and let's see if
she's gonna do it again it might be the
case that she'll kind of go around the
back and then from there no she's not
doing it now I think the game is up a
little bit you know she knows that mom
knows where she is she's not exactly
making herself
unknown at this stage let's see maybe
look you see yeah look at those eyes
there's a plotting eyes aren't they you
see look how she uses the mound so she's
going behind the mound and she might do
the exact same thing as she did just now
which is basically to come over the top
of the mound and then to be able to get
herself into a position there we go you
see what I mean so she's giving in
itself into a position where she can
then strike out and jump on mom she
looks she's poking and then she comes
how cool is that
two cute little one it's such fun
watching little cats play and learn and
we've been spoiled this afternoon
between the sticks Cubs and obviously
shadows little cub and Taylor with Cubs
in the merits lots of little animals at
the moment and it's wonderful to see and
to watch them go about their business
and like I say it's all important and
now we're going to have a ferocious
grooming station which is typical you
can see mom is really cleaning little
one and she's doing the same and this is
quite typical after feeding and moving
around you do see this a lot from a
lipid and her cub what this also might
indicate is that they've decided that
they might move off from here because
you often find with with lipids and and
particularly when they kind of finish
eating they'll clean themselves and then
they go off maybe for water so you might
find that shadow decides that's it we're
gonna leave this carcass to this hyena
and we're gonna carry on and maybe hit
towards tree our stem one of the puddles
somewhere around here for a drink right
now while you watch these two and see
how havoc a shadow yes is don't growl at
me I'm just watching you playing now we
watch these two and see what they get up
to let's go back across to Taylor
mccurdy and her two beautiful male lions
and I wonder if they're going to give us
an audio show for the evening it's
beautiful we've had such an exciting
couple of minutes it was really really
funny but it happened so quickly as does
most things Archer in nature but you
remember our friendly little elephant
that was charging through the bushes he
eventually came through out of nowhere
surprised first Joey and I we had almost
had a heart attack because he trumped it
so loudly and
charging of the bank and he chased our
friend the tale of smell Lian the fella
on the left with the gorgeous man that
was laying flattened was with the
elephant earlier and chased him and then
of course typical displacement behaviour
the elephant chase that I in a way and
then he tried to take his frustrations
out on us and mock charged us but he was
a young boy he must have only been about
seven or eight years old so you know he
was little and I wasn't particularly
worried and I just sort of cest him and
a little laugh at him and I think he was
embarrassed so he kept riding off into
the distance to catch up to the rest of
the elephants so that was quite funny
but it's just these two big boys here
they are rainy rainy lovely cats I think
my favorite out of the triangle boys is
the tailless male now he's not
completely tireless he's just got the
tip missing Tesla Shah again long time
no chat all my little friends are
chatting me today first meter and now
you have made my day my blonde head
friend and now you're wondering if lions
eat any vegetables lions are not very
good at eating vegetables like I hope
you and your brother Ben are and so
Lions don't like to eat vegetables very
much and their mothers cannot force them
to eat their vegetables they I don't
have to sit around the dinner table for
too long they just eat what they want
and I don't think a lion would tell them
any different either
I'd be too scared to tell a lie and
often make it easy vege Tibbles
sometimes what you can see is they'll
eat the grass so I suppose grass is a
bit like a vegetable not one that I'd
want to eat and I much prefer broccoli
cauliflower button that all those
delicious things and anyways so they
will eat lots of grass if they're
feeling a little bit unwell they've got
a hairball it helps helps bring that
back up again and you acting very
playful what's biting you I think
something must be some insect of source
must be nibbling on this line you can
see that Terrell is swatting and it's
not a TAS and he's biting the air
and rolling around like he's playing but
he's not playing even though it looks
very cute
he's probably quite frustrated right now
that he can't get rid of that itch sorry
lovely fella you look like you need to
go to the salon my friend you're a bit
patchy the different colours in his mane
it's quite beautiful like a little
blonde patch there maybe that's the
equivalent of gray hair for a line they
are lovely I don't know where they're
gonna go
I hope they don't go too far and stray
away from the road because we are in a
non off-roading area which is not ideal
able to follow them for very long I'm
actually gonna add a little bit of
lighting here now I can't spotlight
these cats they're not hunting us a car
he's walking in front of my life's mom
and a big boy
aw he goes just casually going for a
stroll so I can spotlight them no
problem when they start hunting however
that will all change we won't be putting
a spotlight on them we've got our
infrared lights on but sometimes it's
just nice to look at predators with a
spotlight but we're going keep it on
them for too long there's no no need
actually should we have a look at him so
you can get some nice pictures because
it is quite nice then I'm not gonna put
it in his eyes either see how I'm just
illuminating just enough to give him a
bit of colour that's what you want to do
when the animals start squinting their
eyes because of the spotlight then you
know you're shining it in the wrong
place as you can see he's got his eyes
wide open at the moment and doesn't mind
mind it and spot lighting techniques are
very very important it's one thing that
they do teach you how to sort of what
correct measures and when and why I kind
of speak when you should use a spotlight
or you shouldn't I think you're gonna
have to get up and move to this so maybe
there's ants in the grass that are
biting them that could be a possibility
matter Bailey and so the cr4
ants they could be nibbling on them it's
just weird that it's not happening to
both of them and they keep rolling over
as if it started on their underside and
then trying to get rid of it maybe
that's how he lost his tail that's
exactly how this line lost her tail they
everybody but it off I'm just joking
that's not true he didn't do that
I'm so sorry krispies can you repeat
yourself
so we go to infrared for something
different we're going to infrared now ah
lovely there we go my friend Tesla this
is that she's renamed the Lions and I
agree with Tesla Tesla says these rinds
names and our I forgotten already Bob
and Bob and someone but I like those
names better I'm sorry I didn't hear
them properly oh sorry
well it was me I wasn't concentrating I
was too busy watching the lion walk past
the car because it's so cool bye mr. cat
again we're gonna reposition we're gonna
have another look at these beauties and
see where they go and let's jump back
onboard with Noel he's also got lines so
mum stood up went over groomed herself
greeted some of the other females and
then came back and it looked like she
was gonna walk right in and greet her
cubs but she laid down oh here we go
here we are mommy I love you I work with
a lot of very rugged staunch men and
even the sight of this makes them say
things like Aqua mooder and cuteness so
it's not just my girly BET's look look
look
so Jean Dre is a staunch manly man and
he's giggling with the light in the
background
so all of this play everything that
we're seeing the grooming the plane with
amongst the Cubs and with mum
remember this is all reaffirming the
social bond oh so not only is she taking
care not only will she groom but this is
it's like when you wake up in the
morning and you give your loved one a
hug or if you have kids and you give
your kids a hug it's the same idea can
we hear the sounds that the little ones
making darkstar you're asking if little
lion cubs can only feed from their
mothers no not only there is something
called a loner scene which is the the
nursing of Cubs amongst females of the
same pride and again that's dependent
upon personality I've seen females that
are very connected and don't mind and
will do that and I've also seen females
kill Cubs of another female and then a
pride because they kept trying too much
but yes it can happen and it's all
individual based gender I don't know if
you can go left here and there's that
one that's eating yes
Shondra commented earlier what a nice
way to spend a Sunday afternoon and like
I said definitely there's no better way
to spend a Sunday afternoon them with
the entertainment that we're having now
also we're getting chaste a little bit
golden sunset light so the colors are
popping out a little bit more
the genre if you wouldn't mind directly
in front of us we have two of the adult
females and one of the youngsters from
the the middle litter who are busy
grooming each other
so to me these two females in front look
relatively the same age so I'm gonna
just say sisters but without knowing the
makeup of the sticks I can't know for
certain notice her teeth marks you can
just see there but she's not suckling
anymore I would guess that she's
probably the mom of the eldest set of
Cubs here I've counted ten Cubs in total
and it looks like seven of which are
males the three different letters again
ten in total and seven that I can see
our males we can see most of them as
Andre pans through there's a sneaky
cheeky one that's found its own it's a
young male who's found its own little
bush left yeah so you can just bear it
there we go that's all you can see of
that one
he's decided but he doesn't want
anything to do with anybody else
now all four of the little Cubs are busy
chewing every piece of bark they can get
Jeff you're wondering do the big cats
have taste buds like us and this
question is actually tickling in my
memory I feel like we found out the
answer to this maybe you have two weeks
ago but for the life of me I can't
remember I know they do have taste buds
but the amount of buds we did figure out
does anyone remember what the amount of
taste buds for a line was I want to say
it something like 160 I can't remember
now but yeah they definitely have taste
buds like we do ah
thanks I was way off it was over ten
thousand for humans with the taste buds
and 474 lions thank you cursed new my
memory tickled correctly just not with
the number itself
I concur on Sondre which we could do a
behind the scenes are of our vehicle
right now because it's just two adults
absolutely caning themselves I know you
can hear me but just do it a little bit
quick quieter in the back so if you go
to the right a little bit generate the
one that's sort of grabbing the other
ones neck there yes they are played but
that grab hold that it was doing there
is actually how it will will grab prey
sometime so a lot of right a lot of the
play that they're doing it will
incorporate their muscles into the
muscle memory that they need later in
life to capture and kill the prey
species they need to do that with there
we go there's a good example again um
for for food and then some of its just
silly play
so I curse what was Phillip asking do
these lions
Philip they didn't take down and kill
the branch themselves the brunch was
already sort of half dead and they're
just massacring the bits off Philip you
have a good sense of humor I'm I'm
enjoying that question right now
all right teyla thinks her lions might
roar who two male lions which is always
fabulous so we're gonna head back to her
don't worry
Chandra and I are not going to go
anywhere we're gonna stay here and we'll
be here when you get back from teyla
don't be like that I heard that these
boys are notorious for playing the gods
I heard that they teased Scott but
eventually his patience war days and
will his patience was well worth it
and they did let out a big roar I reckon
he's listening he's listening around him
so I don't know if there's somebody else
that's contact calling there were some
lionesses and maybe another male line
they were lying out in the open but very
very far away you couldn't maybe I
couldn't really see it there's another
lion roaring
there we go there's the third boy whoa I
just wish that they're all roared at
exactly the same time but it seems as
though the choir needs a bit of work
they obviously haven't been together for
quite some time and you know it takes a
couple of days a practice that bad to
get back into it I think that's exactly
what needs to happen but who knows maybe
they all come together now that they all
know where each other greet each other
do another big rule for us all together
and then I'll be a happy girl then I can
go to bed and go to sleep now me that
was so cool I cannot tell you how I love
for experiences like that
I'm one of the luckiest people alive a
vitual sitting there absolutely and the
way that one started then the other and
then the third and then the fourth just
chiming in that's what magic is made of
for me that was absolutely incredible
where are they now
so I suspect when we first arrived and
we spotted the one line em
animail there too and then the other
fella sounds like he's coming from a
little bit further south so we'll see
we'll sit and wait I was gonna leave but
I don't think I'm gonna leave anymore
however Tristan has I think that you
don't know what he's got but it sounds
like there's another leopard sighting no
no - how installs the Dingman shed and
cub it must be all those cooking of
roast potatoes that has got you a bit
confused today but it is the situation
is pretty much still the same you can
see shadows having a good nap on a
fallen over tree cub has been up and
down and knowing her and kind of
grooming her and it was very cute just
now we had the little Cubs eyes peering
over the back of this fallen over tree
in shadow grooming her and then the paws
on shadows head but for now it's all
kind of settled down they haven't moved
too far from where you last saw as we've
just moved a little bit further south
but not much they can probably still see
where the that hyena is with that caucus
and I think they're just gonna hang
around in the hope that maybe this hyena
needs and they can then get themselves a
bit of food but at this stage it's all
rather sleepy or rather sedate and one
rather very easier and don't think we're
gonna see too much more from them moving
around oh look at that
so Taylor says she was making mashed
potatoes and not roast but why would you
make mashed potatoes on a Sunday
Sunday's are made for roast potato so I
think Taylor has had too much Sun today
and she should maybe not be making
mashed potatoes will be allowed in the
kitchen at all at this stage what do you
think since yes since the Sun has
roasted her brain which i think is quite
fitting but you can see shadows just
pops her head up every now and then she
is far less sort of likely to want to
move there's still panting away that
she's full at the end of the day she ate
all that stomach lining earlier and then
the little cub is the one that is
actually so busy she's the one that's
kind of still head up and looking around
you can see she's trying straight behind
us at the moment at one point she was
lying I would say not even a metre from
our back lift wheel and she was just
staring up at sins as though she wanted
to make friends it was quite amazing
actually watching her an inch she went
back to mom and and
little bit of a chill session with her
and now she's decided she's going to
just plonk over so I think it's going to
be that time in the day we think in a
wrister but before the night time kicks
in and I highly highly highly doubt that
we're going to find them here tomorrow
unless by some miracle they're able to
steal back their kill but even then
they're so little left on there's just
skin and bones and a bit of the neck
area that they would probably finish it
during the course of the night I think
we're gonna find the attract somewhere
around triage damn tomorrow morning and
moving in that general vicinity and I
think they're going to probably in all
likelihood rest around that area well
I'm hoping they will because we'd be
nice to catch up with them again in the
morning it's been so nice to have the
two of them around as much as we have
right now I'm sitting with these two and
watching mom and cub have a wonderful
afternoon together then it seems Noelle
is having an even better afternoon with
the two well four sticks come should I
say not two sticks cuz I'm thinking of
the incomers but the four little sticks
Cubs and all of the sticks females and
well even of Birmingham too it's a
wonderful thing to see and hopefully
they too will stick around over the next
few days alright the females are
starting to get mobile moving slowly but
surely and everyone behind them is going
to start moving as well because they are
of course the leaders of the pride and
for those who might just be joining us
this is the sticks pride we are live we
are interactive so you can send through
your questions hashtag safari live on
the Twitter or on the YouTube chat
you're more than welcome the big Mel one
of one of the big birmingham's has just
set up yes he is a beautiful beautiful
beautiful boy so we've been tracking him
he's just realizing that two of the
females wandered off he's like oh my
goodness where did my females go but he
can still see them a little bit very
aware now sometimes it takes them
forever
I've watched whole prides leave their
males and they've only woken up sort of
30 minutes later going oh my goodness
and then the females do that sometimes
on purpose just to give themselves a
break and then sometimes they just can't
be bothered to wait there's a gorgeous
yawn
and here come the Cubs to greet dad /
uncle depending there's one just in
front of him that's trying to figure out
whether or not he can approach Daryl
you're wondering how often dominant
males will take over another pride
depends on if the males that are in
charge okay let me put it this way so
you get dominant male territorial males
in an area and you get dominant female
prides in an area if those dominant
males go away there's a vacuum for space
for some other males to come in and or a
male if those males that are dominant in
that area are older and there's a
younger coalition that wants to come
through they can take them out and then
the pride that's in that area will then
become their pride sometimes it's a
peaceful takeover and sometimes the
females aren't that happy so remember
you get coalition's of males and you get
prides of females and then males will
attach themselves sometimes to one
sometimes to two sometimes to three
different prides it depends especially
if they've they have it within their
territory more than one pride they are
definitely not always with those females
they have to mark territory and even if
they do have one pride they have to mark
territory and move off so they're not
always although the Cubs are jumping on
dad they're not always with their
females now this is a good dad because
good dads don't turn around and sort of
snap at their little ones it does it
does happen but I mean those are sharp
little claws this male is fully happy to
let her be jungle gym
and it's interesting while he was while
he was sleeping they they didn't want to
bother him much but now that they can
see he's awake they're very very
interested in their in their dad / uncle
[Laughter]
exactly please play with me please Oh
one look
okay all the adult females have gone oh
so that was too much that was too much
for Dad that was a little bit too much
for him a little bit too much pain dad
is not eaten dad / huncles not eaten in
a while he's looking a little bit hungry
most of the females as well looked
hungry so now that all the adult females
have gone off and most of the older Cubs
except for that one at the back these
little Cubs are gonna follow dad through
and then they are going down towards the
water's edge some of them are already
drinking once this big male passes
through I'm gonna just drive forward and
we'll get a good visual I just don't
want to start up the vehicle now I don't
want to scare scare the youngsters his
name is what cursed teen yo uh so so
curse and the sabi sands do they give
not just the coalition's but each
individual a name as well okay really
you're gonna lie down there
alright let's head up to teyla quick
she's got a nocturnal creature for us
that might run away so we'll go up to
her and then all reposition and we'll
get a nice shot for you of them drinking
and of the Cubs playing with dad quick
quick quick quick quick quick quick
there's a whitetail Mongoose where's I
watched our Mongoose gone now yeah
somewhere wasn't too scared delusion
quite relaxed but maybe now them driving
around a problem you know there it is he
tried to trick us stop trying to trick
us Mongoose I'm gonna have to move again
it's going to the edge of that tree hang
on behind that shrub now and I'm just
trying to see where it's coming out so
I've got my spotlight on I can use a
spotlight on this thing though it
doesn't mind it too much
it was just they're just nervous
creatures full stop okay let me go
forward
I will show you it I will I will I will
I will
no man she lead couldn't a run off
where's it hardened it's a sneaky sneaky
sneaky sneaky Oh No okay sorry everybody
yeah but we're really gonna have it this
time it was very relaxed it didn't seem
to mind and they just changed changed
suppose it changed its mind and then
booked out it went behind that tree
somewhere over there but now it's gone
it's what we just sitting flat in the
grass
it'll camouflage very very well whoo aah
Lorrimer you say Mongoose on the loose
on the loose that sounds like a great
song I could probably dance to that yes
it is the Mongoose on the loose but it
is not a mungry something we said we're
going to see unfortunately well that's
sad maybe we find another one let's
quickly have a look this area is filled
with creatures of the nights is actually
quite nice and the LA to back Arthur
gain tonight I can confirm this because
they've pulled all the way up my legs
already and they're also flying into my
head and into the lights so that is very
good news for us or for those that want
to see little small mach kernel
creatures we might have a good chance
this evening we could see owls which are
very exciting we don't often see hours
of the Mara we could see more white
tailed Mongoose snakes I would like to
see a rock python I would also like to
see a brown half snake eating l8 I would
like to see some frogs and be some
bullfrogs
feasting upon them two bats oh no no
maybe not that I said that that's
preferable small insects I've never seen
a microchiroptera vet
eating a term I sometimes I talk
absolute nonsense you don't listen to
the things I say listen rather listen to
Jamie and bring two J's and Tristan to
nowhere
I'll just be here for the funny things
give me all the hilarious sightings okay
wait we're gonna find another one I'm
convinced so I'm concentrating now
because I'm looking for the reflection
of the eyes
where are you are we gonna find a
striped polecat oh I see eyes I see eyes
I see it it's running it's something
it's an I'm sure it's another
white-tailed Mongoose hold on a little
bit vampy okay I'm going to use the yes
it's a white tailed Mongoose it's not
the one that I was talking about but
it's another one and the lion is roaring
listen
this is the same your glance did you see
that not even acknowledging that the
lion is roaring how rude because I think
that beautiful sorry I'm jumping around
the car trying to la self my legs
did you see how it's actually depositors
and little bits of something on a piece
of grass and anal secretion something
similar to that quite a little
territorial control very exciting
let's see mating Mongoose I'm trying to
follow it with the spa cycle it's just a
little bit too far away for the shoes my
shoe there's not even any room baby for
my feet but James you're wondering if
there's any purpose to that whitetail
perhaps it's to try and confuse
predators and make them and think that
there's something like a skunk I mean
it's got very similar markings or maybe
it's savage like a honey badger who game
got some of the markings I don't know if
there's an exact function probably is
I'd however it's not a follow me sign I
think
follow me signs a predominantly full
sort of diurnal animals in terms of
something like that you know that is
obvious and and they're not diurnal
animals I don't know how well white sort
of sticks are from the black of the
night you don't have an artificial light
on it I can't see that color with white
from can't see it so I couldn't can't
actually comment on that and so I wonder
if it's just maybe to try and confuse
something and make it look as if it was
the skunk of sorts because we know that
animals that do you have sort of small
as foul-smelling substances that they
will either squirt art will secrete
typically are black and white and color
so a view symmetric coloration they're
just tasteful perhaps right we're gonna
keep bubbling I think we're gonna find
plenty watch held mongoose this evening
which is very exciting
so I'm going to keep searching for them
as well as owls Noel is still sitting
with a very adorable lions
the majority of the pride has come down
for a drink dad such uncle so we're just
gonna call him the mal what did you guys
calm t know one of the Birmingham boys
is still up on the damn wall with the
little ones we actually came down and
positioned the way we did because we
want to get some really nice visuals for
you face front of these females and the
older sets of Cubs so we're just going
to wait here and see what transpires
there's that reaffirming the social bond
we chatted about earlier
the muscles in it Jessica she has not
this is the mum you can actually see
I'll don't lie down before she laid down
you could see her her swollen teats
there but they have not eaten I would
say within the last sort of four or five
days that would be my guest of it and
this is a perfect time for them to start
to hunt
to the N it's good to hear your voice I
haven't heard you in a while I'm truly
answer did you ask our baby Lyons cute
to hold like your kittens was that the
question curse Clause like the uh-huh
I've got you yah they're just like your
kittens clause exactly like that and
they're really sharp they are they are
dangerous little implements as it were
and if you have a kitten then you would
know exactly exactly what it feels like
and even your kittens little teeth are
the same as those those baby lions
that one's coming in for a bath it's
bath time this time of night is my
favorite time of night so the sun's gone
down we probably have about another sort
of 15 minutes of usable lights maybe
maybe 10 and with it wasn't extremely
warm by any means today but this getting
ready this lion getting ready for the
evening and and for making their way
around is one of my favorite evening
rituals to watch it never gets old to me
I am never disappointed
and I'm quite in love with most of these
adult females in this group they've got
really stunning golden golden eyes I
mean look at the muscles on her she's
got Bulldog type muscles you can see
she's a very good hunter you can see
she's been a good mum over the years and
and raised some little ones
[Laughter]
that one still wants more bath time
there you can see how she's drooping
though this is the mother of the little
ones can you see the difference with her
who's lactating as opposed to the other
females oh sorry I'm lying I'm lying to
you that's the female with the middle
set of cups then if we come the one
that's passing by me now this is the
female with the eldest set of Cubs and
then the one coming through now is the
one with the youngest Cubs you see the
difference in the lactation there
so the big melt that I can see hasn't
moved yet
and I'm wondering if he might stay
behind with the little little ones I
have seen that come um I have seen that
come I have seen that happened before
let's go back up to teyla and kenya
quickly and we will stay with the sticks
as they meander off see what Taylor has
in store for us we've got a janitor
that's after all the El AIDS it's far
far away there against the tree line
with the Mara River is perfect spot for
a Jenner there it is hopping about sheep
jumping around oh my goodness I wish my
spotlight was stronger what are they
doing in there I wonder if is just
chasing after and leaping into the air
after the after all the LA isn't gonna
come out again Janet please I was very
excited I've never seen a Janet bounce
around so much my entire life very cool
anyways it's now gone into the tree line
we might find more let's look let's
search it's be like Rihanna and Search
Search Search Search Search just joking
hope that song is now stuck in one of
your head ha ha ha I'm so evil
ok it's and it's also not that lyrics I
know don't worry in case you think Oh
hyena oh you know where are you running
to shall we shall we run with you fly
Wayans I'm just gonna dry the car very
slowly nix the high unit as it walks
I've also got my spotlight out I'm using
it tonight not too much though just
every now and then again is just using
it to enhance the infrared light it's
very far away how cool is that shadow
that it's costing that's quite eerie
looks of its like a werewolf actually
note that reminds me of a brown hyena
the shadow that it's casting
they're stopping having a little look
around you might even see the LA it's
buzzing about what have you heard
listening very carefully to what the
night has to say changing direction
completely now so something must have
intrigued it's now going waste rather
than South very interesting
I love seeing all these critters of the
night don't you I just assume that
you've all said yes Taylor of course I
make up my own answers into the head to
what you're all thinking that's why I
have so much fun on Safari
this could also be good chameleon
country - that's for sure with all the
trees that are around oh hippopotamus
crossing look at all the animals I'm
seeing hello every one of us I didn't
mean to shout I shall leave my light off
for the hippopotamus he's deciding if
he's or she excuse me madam you could be
a madam deciding whether or not you're
going to cross the road are you a
chicken I feel like there's a horrible
joke joke waiting here come on share
them hashtags very life what is the
funniest thing you can think of about a
hippo crossing the road and go and while
we wait for this fella to cross the road
oh girl it's going across to Tristan
he's decided he's not missing out on the
fun he's back with the spots I am back
with shadow well I actually didn't
really leave her it to be honest as you
can see she's just gonna cross the road
behind me and I don't know if she's
gonna hit down the road or what her
story is going to me it looks like she
might actually just lie down somewhere
there it could be that she just feels
like rather being on the road itself so
I'm just going to turn around so it's in
Zoe's doesn't have to have cables and
aerials and all kinds of other things in
his way because you can see she's lying
directly behind me now the cub is off to
my left he was busy trying to follow
around with hyenas and try and play that
game so that's what that one's busy with
but
the shadow will just lie down and she'll
be children will be able to finish on
evening with the two of them it's been
such a wonderful thing I was going to
leave because they were the vehicles
that wanted to come but then everybody
said that they'll leave in stage and so
we're in a situation now I can just stay
with these two which is absolutely
wonderful really so we've had such a
cool afternoon it's been a lipid
sighting where they haven't stopped -
sorry [ __ ] use the accelerator just
not just let out the clutch but we
haven't had the situation where the two
of them have really stopped for too long
the softening they've been up and down
all over the place and it's just been so
nice to actually spend time with them
and a lot of its by ourselves which has
been really wonderful but I think
shadows decided the the road is a much
better place to lie at the moment then
in the grass it's probably find the
nests insects crawling on Earnest of any
sort of obstructions of grass and
various other things and she's worked
out that that's exactly where she wants
to be and she's looking about as regal
as you could possibly get from a leopard
there is nothing better though I must be
honest when you come around a corner and
you see that lying in the road it is
seemingly the best thing if I absolutely
love watch when you come around to the
corner you find a participation if
you've had a tough day you've been
trying to find it trying to find it and
then you come around and you see
something like this I know this
afternoon has not been the case but
whenever I see a lip in the road like
there's always think of the times when
we track them and it's nice if they
would do this a little bit more often
than what they actually do because a lot
of the time we end up in a situation
where we look for them everywhere and
they very seldom actually lie on the
road suckers Lions a lot of the time on
roads but lipids not nearly as much as
what you see from the Lions but she's
starting to get quite sleepy you can see
that head is starting to sort of bow
down and I think it's gonna be a
situation where she's eventually going
to just fall asleep right there it's
probably the most comfortable spot for
at the moment I'm not sure the cub is
gone like I said it was around and fala
king with I you know behind me whether
or not it's still doing that so quite
sure I think this stage is a situation
where the hyenas probably still just
chewing away I heard some crunching of
bones just now so I'm pretty sure that
hyena still got the carcass and still
feeding and don't think it's going to
let go of it at all right it seems as
though Taylor mccurdy who as a bit tardy
has also become a little bit more awake
in the last few minutes and has found
many many things this evening that
of the nocturnal variety and she's now I
believe what's another one of those
Mongoose with big white fluffy tails
this Mongoose is after roast potatoes
Tristan that's sort of sucking for
typically the roast potatoes that are on
the road this is a cool little
white-tailed Mongoose too because it
doesn't seem to be so shy it's running
about and doing its thing in Clear View
for us which is quite nice and very very
busy I think it's looking again I keep
saying they're looking for the la la
it's there's lots of little beetles
little chafers around too so it could be
going for that but I mean ideally you
want to find where all those el aids are
being expelled from don't you because
that are they real because that is going
to be a gold mine there you go marking
scent marking of course bye bye
office going again this is really
interesting to watch them I've never
actually seen them scent mark before
we're very much like among groups of YV
I have seen small grey Mongoose Santa
mark but I have never seen the white
tailed long this is the first time
they've ever sat still thank you let me
go up a bit further forward it's even
get another view we having lots of luck
with all the little creatures and it's
also a hippo City our chair I have seen
maybe about 30 or 40 hippos already just
everywhere you know they were all
charging into us just about because
they're trying to come out of their
tunnels in the forest are you gonna stay
for one last view let's see it's going
up the mound yeah I think it's getting
lucky now with finding we're finding
where exactly other things gone now it
was on top of the mound
it is disappeared on to the other side I
know there it is to the right there you
go it's just running off to the right
hand side it's disappeared
and it's gone into the bushes we can't
see it anymore
that's okay we've seen so many of them
probably gonna see a whole bunch more
it's a good night really really is a
good night for nocturnal critters and we
concentrate over this little bridge
no chameleons here sadly I'm not the
communion Queen chameleon queen in juma
no I am the chameleon Queen in Juma and
I am NOT the chameleon Queen in Kenya
I'm just the marshmallow Queen anyways
it's been great and I'll see you all
tomorrow morning I'm going to send you
back across with Noel and of course the
double nine cups started segment shot to
be him walking into camera yeah yeah
that's exactly what I want I mean he's
following them and they walked right
here so he should turn and come straight
at us
now unfortunately no one's had a few
gremlins and so back with us as we make
our way back home we just lived shadow
right now one of the other vehicles that
was there she was way she was lying he
has some photographic yes and so we let
him have our position because we had
such a nice sort of spot day so left
that for them to enjoy and kind of enjoy
the evening they only just got going now
thank you they arrived a bit late so I'm
sure they're going to have a wonderful
evening with so much around believing in
kuma pride was seen on before hook this
afternoon as well which is quite nice
and that one line is from the in kuma
problems also found around before hook
dam which is very very cool so lots
going on lots happening and it's
excellent news that the sticks are
walking north of course I know the
sticks can cover massive distance and
chances are they probably will head
towards Torchwood but you never know
maybe they're gonna end up hanging
around for tomorrow morning's drive as
well and they've believed those Cubs are
super cute so really really really great
to have them around as well and I was
just saying to Senza as we were kind of
driving home now
what an incredible afternoon it's been
from all sides I mean it started with a
bang with Scotts cheetah kill and then
we had the little eggs and obviously
we've had lots of other baby animals
this afternoon so it's been really a
special afternoon and
everybody's had a wonderful time of it I
know taylor loves lions roaring and i
guess i squatted the cheetahs and
various other sightings that we've had
but unfortunately it's all that we've
got time for so from Scott myself Taylor
and Noel it's been a pleasure we'll see
you all tomorrow morning on the Sunrise
Safari and remember it's a little bit
earlier tomorrow morning
you
you